سيله الطروات تتسارع في المناطق الشماليه
رغم الحديث عن انسحابات كبيره في القاطع
الشمالي من قطع غزه لقوات الاحتلال نحللها
مع اللواء فيس دويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك لواء دويري سلام
اطلعي على ابرز نقاط الاشتباك بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال لا
سيما في الشمال من الشمال سنبدا اذا جلال
عادت المنطقه الشماليه في اليوم الع بعد
المئه لتكون منطقه اشتباكات قويه بين
فصائل ال المقاومه والقوات الاسرائيليه
تتركز بطبيعه الحال هذه الاشتباكات عند
غرب وجنوب غرب مدينه غزه الى حد بعيد
منطقه تل الهواء عادت لتكون منطقه
اشتباكات قاسيه وقويه هذه المنطقه قوات
الاحتلال سبق وقالت انها قضت على واحده من
ابرز
الكتائب المقاتله ضمن قوات المقاومه لكن
عادت لهواء لتكون اليوم منطقه اشتباك
شديده هناك استهدافات لجنود اسرائيليين
وايضا هناك استهدافات لاليات اسرائيليه
الاخبار العاجله التي تناولناها قبل قليل
تتحدث عن وجود اشتباكات في منطقه
الجامعات بين منطقه الجامعات بالاحرى
ومنطقه الجوازات وهما منطقتان
متجاورتان تقريبا هذه ليست خريطه الشمال
نعود الى الشمال جنوب وجنوب غرب مدينه غزه
هي مناطق اشتباكات قويه وهناك عمليات قنص
تنفذها قوات الاحتلال الى جنوب المدينه
للمواطنين الذين يتحركون بين الاحياء
الداخليه للمدينه بموازاه هذه التطورات في
شمال
القطاع اليوم هناك
اي نقطه جديده يجب ان نتحدث عنها خان يونس
منطقه خان يونس التي دخلتها قوات الاحت
احلال قبل 120 يوما من بعض المناطق في
الوسط عبر شارع صلاح الدين توغلت اليها
وايضا دخلتها من محاور اخرى
في
شرق المنطقه الجنوبيه دخلتها في محاوله
للوصول الى مدينه خان يونس الى قلب مدينه
خان يونس لكن حتى الان لم تدخل قوات
الاحتلال الى قلب مدينه خانيونس
اليوم اكملت محافظه خانيونس اليوم ال 120
من القتال مع قوات الاحتلال الجيش
الاسرائيلي يوف جالن تحدث قبل ثلاثه ايام
عن ان العمليات الكبرى قد انتهت في
المنطقه في محافظه خانيونس
والمناطق المحيطه بها ولكن حتى الان اليوم
هناك استهدافات من كتائب المقاومه في اكثر
من منطقه خاصه غرب مدينه خان يونس جلال
هذه تحتاج الى تحليل وقراءه للوضع في
السياق معك واللواء الدوير خاصه عوده
المواجهات بحده في مناطق الشمال هذا يعني
لواء دويري بان الانسحابات ليست كامله في
مناطق الشمال الانسحابات ليست كامله
بالتاكيد لانه ما المعارك موجوده عمليات
القنص موجوده وهي موجوده كما اشارت في
مربع الجامعات ومربع الجوازات ومع شارع
النصر وبالتالي الاطراف الجنوبيه ل الرمال
الجنوبي ولتل الهواء ا لكن السؤال المطروح
هل هذه القوه مرتبطه بالويه الفرقه 162
التي تم سحبها لانه كانت فيها ثلاث الويه
زائد كتيبه سحب لواء لوحده ثم سحب اعلن
سحب بقيه الفرقه هناك لوائين موجود يتواجد
في منطقه وادي غزه من جحر الديك جسر وادي
غزه وحتى اطراف الشاطئ اعتقد ان القوات
التي تقا يعني متواجده الان هي تعود الى
تلك القوات بينما الفرقه 162 تم انسحابها
ومن المرجح انه تم انسحابها الى داخل
الغلاف لماذا نعم هذه المنطقه الشماليه
تعتبر منطقه رخوه ولكنها منطقه غير امنه
يوجد بها انفاق هذه الانفاق لم تكتشف بعد
وبالتالي ستكون مؤلمه لجيش الاحتلال
فسيكون انسحابه الى داخل الغلاف القوات
اللي الان تشتبك ومع المقاومه هي اعتقد
تعود الى القوات المتواجده في وادي غزه
وهذه كانت موجوده لاكثر من سبب السبب
الاول
اشغال الزيتون وتل الهواء والشيخ عجلين
ومنعهم من تقديم اسناد الى منطقه الوسط
لانه كانت الفرقه 36 فشلت رسلت الفرقه
99 استطاعت ان تحقق الفصل بين المخيمات
انما كانوا يخشون من نقطه انتقال المقاومه
من شمال الوادي الى جنوب الوادي وبالتالي
ابقي على لوائين في تلك المنطقه فاعتقد ان
القوات التي تقاتل او الان تشتبك مع
المقاومه في تل الهواء والرمال هي تعود
الى القوات الموجوده في وادي غزه نشاهد
فيديو بثته سرايا القدس لسير المعارك في
قطاع غزه
نتابع
[موسيقى]
الله الله
[تصفيق]
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر ولله الحمد
[موسيقى]
c
بسم الله الله
اكبر اذا لواء دويري تابعنا هذه الصور من
سرايا القدس الاعلام الحربي لاطلاق هاون
باحجام مختلفه على ما يبدو الهاون يعني
بان المسافه
قريبه الحد الاقصى 120 ملم 7 كيلو فمدى
عاده ما بين 5 الى 7 كيلو
حسب نوع المقذوف لانه هذا يوجد فيه حشوات
وبالتالي هي اللي تحدد خط المحرك ارتفاع
المحرك والمدى كل ما ارتفع المحرك كل ما
زاد المدى واضح هذا في خان في خان يونس في
خان يونس هذا اعتقد انه 80 او 60 يعني
الدايا متر لا يمكن ان يظهر معنا ان نحدده
لكن بما انه تستخدم يد واحده في التلقيم
سيكون من الحجم المتوسط
اها درجه ميلان
السبطانه تدل الى شيء الان انظر الى
الامام على ماذا يرتكز هذا يسمى جهاز
الملز اللي انت تتحكم فيه من الانحراف
يمين او يسار للاسفل او للاعلى كلما كانت
الزاويه اقرب الى العموديه كلما كان
المحرك اعلى والمدى والمدى ابعد ابعد لانه
نلاحظ هنا بانه ميزته هو اصلا تاريخيا كان
يستخدم للرمايه من خلف التلال لكن الان
هذه معارك داخل مناطق مبنيه فهو يرمي من
خلف جدار او من خلف نلاحظ هنا الميلان هنا
اقل اه اقل اقل نعم اقل اه هنا اكثر مرتفع
اكثر لانه هذا الان هو يعني عمليه الرماء
اولا يتم تحديد مكان الهدف وقياس المسافه
الان يوجه وهو يعتبر يستخدم يستخدم ضد
اهداف منطقه وليست نقطه وبالتالي الان يتم
قياس المسافه ويتم
الان
اجراء المعادلات من اجل ان ان ان يكون
اصابته دقيقه تكون هي تقاس عاده بالملز
وزاويه الارتفاع وغير ذلك ايضا الوا دويري
الجزيره حصلت على صور حصريه لقصف
واشتباكات بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
والاحتلال في في محيط مستشفى الشفاء
بمدينه
غزه يعني منطقه ال الجنوب الغربي من مدينه
غزه لا تزال اشتباكات قائمه فيها الان
الشفاء يوجد في نفس المنطقه تل الهواء
الشيخ عجلين الاطراف الجنوبيه من الرمال
الجنوبي وبالتالي مجمع الجامعات مجمع
الجوازات وشارع النصر هذه المنطقه لا يزاد
يوجد فيها اي
قوات تابعه لجيش الاحتلال لاحظ لواء دويري
رغم اصوات الاشتباكات الكثيفه الا ان
المتواجدين في محيط المستشفى يعني و وكان
شيئا يعني لا يحصل الانسان يتكيف مع
البيئه الانسان يتكيف مع البيئه الان هذه
معركه لها 120 يوم لا يمكن ان يبقى
الانسان مغلق على نفسه صحيح يستطيع
وبالتالي يصبح لا اقول تعايش سعيد لكن لا
هو تعايش مع ظرف صعب ام لانه هناك
احتياجات لابد ان الانسان يسعى للحصول
عليها ولو اجل رغيف الخبز يجب ان يخرج
ويجلب هذه الاحتياجات وبالتالي هم بداوا
يتعايشوا مع هذا الواقع هو اللافت بعوده
الاشتباكات الى محيط مستشفى الشفاء الذي
شهد ما شهده في في بدايه التوغل
الاسرائيلي الان هذه التدخلات
يعني هي تاتي بناء على تحديات طارئه من
قبل المقاومه لانه هم
اهدافهم
واضحه معلومات عن الخنا عن الانفاق عن
الرهائن عن المقاتلين وبالتالي هنا يكون
العمل جزء منه استدراج يعني المقاومه
تستدرج لماذا لانه اذا لم يكن ضمن مدى
اسلحه المقاومه المسافه صفر هو سيكون الان
في ما في امان كامل باستثناء انه يطلق
النار عليه شكرا اللواء دويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي شكرا لك